Hello everyone
and welcome to lecture four of C E 296.
So before we start, I just want to say
that those first three lectures were
really the most technically and
mathematically challenging.
So in that sense, I'm still glad you're
here.
And I really hope that those three
lectures gave you the intuition as to
why we are going to use this generation
paradigm
because they are going to be used as
building blocks for everything that
we're going to see
from now on.
In particular
during the first three lectures
we focused on unconditional generation.
And now what we're going to see is how
we can generate images
with a condition which can be the user
prompt
like input text
or an input image.
And so in that sense, the title of
today's lecture is multimodal guided
generation.
With that
we're going to start.
And as usual, I'm going to just recap
what we did the previous times.
So as I mentioned, the first three
lectures were mathematically challenging
and they were about
seeing how we could generate images,
what were the paradigms that we could
use.
So the first lecture was focused on the
diffusion paradigm with DDPM
where we saw that we were taking clean
images that we were noising in a
discrete way.
And so here we had this formula which
was a combination of a clean image and
Gaussian noise that we weighted with
those coefficients.
And what we saw with a bunch of math was
that we could derive an expression that
we could optimize in order to
reconstruct those clean images that we
we've noised.
And we ended up with a very nice
expression, an L2 loss on the noise that
was added.
And in particular, if we wanted to
denoise, we had the following formula
that
allowed you to go from a step T
to step T minus one
using this model E theta which was the
predicted noise that was added.
And so in that sense, it was
parameterized with respect to the noise
epsilon.
Then in lecture two, what we did was
that
we derived the continuous version of
what we derived in a discrete way in
lecture one.
And we also saw a second paradigm, a
second way of seeing things which was
score matching.
And we saw that
when we looked at these two way two ways
of doing things
if we were to
take
the increment of time from T to T plus
one and
tended to zero
we had a general expression of the
increment in X which would be as a
function of DT, the increment in time,
and DW
which is the continuous version of
adding noise.
And in particular, you had these two
terms. So on the left side
the
drift term and then on the right side
was the diffusion term.
And we saw that in order to reverse
the noise that was added, so aka reverse
process
we could use a result from theories on
stochastic differential differential
equations where we saw that
we could
derive the reverse process if we knew
the score.
Which is why this formulation was
parameterized as a function of the
score.
So here's noted S of theta.
And in lecture three
we saw that actually
we could think of this whole thing as a
completely in a completely different
way.
And we can think of it as transporting a
probability mass from an initial
distribution up to a target
distribution. And in that sense, we
could express
a
noisy image as a combination of noise
and
sample from the target distribution.
And all of what we had to do was to just
predict the vector field, aka the
velocity.
Which was noted U of theta.
But
one thing that we kept
silent was
how we could actually represent all
these quantities, in particular
XT
the representation of the image when
it's noised at a given level
the noise itself.
All of these we just assumed that there
was some way of representing these in
some N or D dimensional space.
So one thing that we will do today is
to see what space could actually be more
appropriate for this kind of work.
And then the second thing is as you can
see
the
models that we need to estimate, so
epsilon theta, S of theta, U of theta,
they're only a function of the noised
image and the time.
But they're not a function of any
condition.
Any user inputs.
So this is also something that we're
going to see.
Aka how can we incorporate a condition
that could guide the generation
towards what we want.
So this is the menu for today.
So
to recap, we're going to see three
things. The first one is how can we
represent those noisy images?
The second thing that we're going to see
is how to represent the conditions that
we want as inputs. So for instance the
input text here, a teddy bear reading a
book that we want to generate an image
for
or an input image that you want to to
condition your generation for.
And then the third thing is how we can
guide the generation process using that
as an input.
So we're going to start with number one,
how to represent these noisy images.
And I'm going to start
with
the most natural approach that you could
have when you see those images.
We as humans
we're very accustomed to seeing things
in the pixel space.
So here if you take this image as an
example, this image has a certain height
H, a certain width W.
So what you can do is to represent each
pixel
as a function of the intensity
of the color that composes it.
And in particular, a very common
representation is using R, so red, green
and blue.
So in other words
you would have
each pixel that would have three values
which would make up the color.
And you would have these values cover
all pixels of the image.
So you would have a dimension N
that would be equal to three times
the size, the number of pixels, which is
H times W.
And so you could represent your image as
a tensor
along the axis
the height, the width
and the number of channels here which
are three which represents R, G and B.
So this could be one way.
But
the big problem with that is that it's
very high dimension.
So
if we take the example of a quote
unquote regular image, so 1024 * 1024
pixels
then we would end up with a number of
dimensions which would be on the order
of a million.
So 10 to the power of six.
And if you think about it
this is just a lot of dimensions to
consider in our trainer generation
paradigms
which are of course a function of the
dimension in which you operate.
So that's one very big drawback.
The second drawback is if you look at
your image
you actually see that you have a lot of
redundancies.
So if you see for instance in a given
neighborhood of pixels, you have a lot
of very similar values.
So in a sense, you can consider this as
a waste of dimensions. So it's not very
compact.
And then the third thing is
if you remember our whole first three
lectures were about taking the image and
you know, adding noise and then just
moving it in the space with respect to
added noise.
Well,
here if you take an image
and you were to move it slightly in that
space by adding some noise,
you would actually obtain
an image noisy image that would actually
not be very meaningful.
It would not It would not mean anything.
So, in particular, uh so I'm not sure if
you recall these nice
graphs or charts where you would see the
areas of high density of uh your target
desired distribution.
So, here what we want is clusters of
observations that are likely to occur,
but what we get is actually the thing on
the right, which is a space with very
spiky regions
where each spike represents
uh an actual valid image.
And that's not good.
So, for all these reasons,
we're going to just come up with the
wish list
of a space that we would like to have.
So, I'm going to go through that step by
step.
So, the first one is the high
dimensionality observation that I made.
So, here what we want is a dimension
that's more  unquote tractable.
So, that's our number one.
Number two of our wish list is to have a
representation that does not have a lot
of redundancies, that has some
um some way of compacting things. So,
number two is compact representation.
Number three regarding the
representation not being meaningful. So,
here we want a representation that is
meaningful.
And you can think of this when I say,
you know, what meaningful means.
It's when you look at the space and
you're able to
have clusters of regions where valid
images happen.
That's what I mean by meaningful space.
So, this is our wish list.
So,
before we move ahead,
I want to take the time to introduce
two terminologies
that are widely used in those papers.
So, I prefer to define them now and
clearly so that you know what they refer
to.
So, you will see that there's a lot of
talk about semantic similarity. So, what
does semantic similarity mean?
So, semantic similarity of an image
is something that refers to its global
geometry, to its overall structure.
And in particular, what that means is if
two images are semantically similar,
what that means is that they roughly
represent the same thing.
So, here on the slide you have on the
left a teddy bear that is reading a
book.
On the right you have also teddy bear
that is reading a book. They're not
exactly aligned pixel wise,
but they're semantically similar.
So, that's for semantic similarity.
Now you have another notation,
which is perceptual similarity.
So, this one refers to more of the of
the local details of an image, more to
the lower level texture of an image.
And when you say that two images are
perceptually similar,
what that means is that to the human
eye,
they look the same.
So, for instance, you have again two
pictures of a teddy bear. So, I'm not
sure if you see the one on the right has
some little glasses,
but it's perceptually very similar.
Does that make sense? That that
distinction?
Yeah?
The reason why I say that is I'm going
to use that terminology going forward,
so I just want to make sure we all know
what these are.
So,
what are we doing? What we want is to
come up with a space
that fulfills our wish wish list that we
established before.
So, here is our first attempt.
So, how about
we take an image
in the pixel space
and what we try to do
is
find a representation that's meaningful
using the following architecture.
So, let's assume we take that image
and we put it into some
model, let's call it an encoder,
that encodes the image
and produces an output that is of lower
dimensionality as the input.
So, here we go from an image of size H W
and number of channels, which as you
know is equal to three uh in the pixel
space because you're like in the RGB
representation.
And here we end up with a latent
representation of size lower cage lower
case H, lower case W,
and little C.
And then what we do is
we put that representation back
to the decoder. So, if we were to do
that,
our objective is to recover
the original image.
So, we don't want to lose any
information by
encoding our image into a lower
dimensional space. So, here such a setup
is called an autoencoder.
So, the only job of an autoencoder
is to find a lower dimension
representation that's called
the latent representation.
And what it does is
take an image in the pixel space as
input,
compress it,
and then decode it.
And here the task is making sure that
what you get as output
is the same as what you get as input.
So, you may think, okay, it's a very
useless model,
uh which I agree,
unless you're interested in the latent
space, which we are.
This is what we're interested in.
So, does this setup make sense?
Cool. And then uh terminology wise, the
latent space
uh like that part is called the
bottleneck just because we're forcing
the model to rely on fewer dimensions.
And we want the model to still preserve
the richness of the details that are
present in the image.
So, let's see how we do that, but before
we go, I want to introduce another
notation
that you also see a lot in papers, which
is called
the spatial compression compression
ratio,
which is defined by the amount by which
you go from big H to little H.
So, it's just a ratio between the two.
And that ratio is typically on the order
of eight.
So, that's the order of magnitude that
you should have in mind.
Cool. So, let's see now based on what I
told you,
how each component works.
So,
in terms of what is input in the
encoder, as we mentioned, we have our
input image, let's note it X,
that we put in our encoder that we note
E phi,
and we get a latent representation Z
that is equal to E phi of X.
And so, the way we would do that
would be to use a network
that contains some down sampling
operations.
So, what that means is it allows us to
go from a bigger dimension to a lower
dimension.
We're not going to go into too much
details into what that network is
because we're going to talk more about
this in the next lecture,
but I just want to tell you
roughly the two main operations that you
can expect,
which you may have seen. So, the first
one is convolutions.
So, who has heard of convolutions
before?
Yeah? Everyone? Okay, so I can go fast.
Convolutions is just a way to scan your
image using a filter.
So, the image is in red, the filter is
in blue, and what you get is what we
call
an activation map or a a feature map
that is
in uh purple.
And then the second operation that you
see in these kinds of networks is
pooling.
So, pooling is a down sampling
operator that allows you to either take
the maximum of a given square or the
average or either max pooling or average
pooling.
And it allows you to introduce some
spatial invariance just because you can
aggregate the pixels
to a higher
granularity.
We're not going to go into too much
detail, but these are just for
reference. So, when it comes to the
decoder, what you would do is
take the latent representation Z
into the decoder D theta
and you would get your reconstructed
output X hat.
So, here you would use upsampling
operations, for instance, reverse
convolutions.
And the goal of this model
is
as much as possible for your
reconstructed output
to be as close as possible to your
input.
So, the loss function of such a model
would be
something along the lines of just L2
regression
between the input X
and the reconstructed input
X hat.
So, I have a question for you.
Do you think this model is a good model?
So, this is what we're going to see now.
So, let's go through our checklist.
First one is, okay, is the dimension
more tractable?
Yes, more tractable.
Is the representation more compact?
Yes, it's more compact.
Is the representation
meaningful? Meaning, do you have a nice
shape in your latent space in the way we
represent it?
Yes, exactly. Not necessarily.
Well, the reason for that is we have not
constrained our latent space to be
structured in any particular way.
So, the model is just only incentivized
to reconstruct the input
as best as it can
and it really doesn't care what
shape the latent space is.
So, you actually still end up with this
kind of space.
Which is not good.
This is not good because your flow
matching model, your diffusion model is
just not able to learn very well in the
spaces because, first of all, the
representations are all over the place.
And if you remember
one common thing with all of these
generation paradigms
is that you start from a normal
distribution. Like a standard normal
distribution.
So, you need a way for you to not get
lost.
So, if everything is far apart
it just doesn't work.
So, that's not good.
So, let's go back to the drawing boards
and let's see what we can change.
So, we take our image, we compress it,
and then we decompress it.
Everything's perfect.
Well, let's see what we can do in the
latent space.
Our goal here would be to
enforce the latent space to
have some structure.
So, this is our goal.
And we're going to see how we can do
that.
Okay, let's go back to where we were. We
take our input image X.
But instead of just letting it through a
standard encoder
what we will do
is to actually
not try to
predict
or generate
the latent representation directly.
We will actually predict
two things.
The mean
and the standard deviation
of the distribution that it can be drawn
from.
So, in other words
what we're going to say to say is
instead of saying that one X corresponds
to one latent representation
we're going to say that
one X
actually is mapped
to some probability distribution.
Which sounds kind of weird, right?
It's not very natural.
But we're going to see why that
mitigates the problem.
So, here as a reminder, so the output of
the encoder will not be just
a latent vector.
It will be so, the mean mu phi
and the variance sigma squared phi.
So, these are the two
outputs of the encoder and what we will
say is that the latent representation
of
this distribution
this latent representation is actually
drawn from this distribution. That's
what we're going to going to say.
And we're going to say something else.
So, in a bit of an informal way
we're going to say that this
distribution
is going to be roughly forced
to follow or to approximate another
distribution.
So, it's not very mathematically
rigorous. We we were going to see
exactly how we can express that.
But in your mind, I want you to know
that
this is a condition for us
to structure the latent space in a way
where we say
the latent representation of an input X
will be roughly in a given region of the
space. We're going to force that. We're
going to incentivize the model to learn
that.
So, that's the idea.
Cool. And yeah, this
distribution is, okay, you may have
guessed it. Again, a standard normal
distribution just because it's uh
it's a nice distribution with great
properties.
And by the way, this distribution we're
going to call it the prior, the prior
distribution.
So, let's see how the decoder works.
So, let's assume we have put our input
image into the encoder, we have
predicted the mean, we have predicted
the standard deviation, we have drawn
a latent representation from the
distribution.
So, now the decoding stage would be
around taking that representation
and passing it through
the [snorts] decoder which again will
output
two things.
The mean
mu theta of this latent representation Z
and standard deviation.
And what we're going to say is again
that
the reconstructed image
is going to be drawn
from a probability distribution
of these two parameters.
Well, one thing that I want to say is
actually
we're going to simplify this part of the
problem a little bit.
We're actually going to say that the
variance is not something we're going to
predict. We're just going to
fix it to be constant.
Just because
there is less impact in you
making sure to introduce some variation
in the output because in the pixel space
even if you add a little bit of noise
it's not going to change the image a
whole lot.
So, that's why
people just say, okay, we're going to
take some variance that's
constant, fixed, and we're not going to
predict that.
We're only going to predict the mean. We
can draw from this distribution.
But sometimes people also just take the
mean
as the output.
This part is more of a detail.
Yeah. So, the question here is that
whether the latent Z is drawn from the
Gaussian or is drawn from the Q the
encoder here Q phi Z given X. So, it's a
great question. So, this
model which we're going to see what the
name is
is both a model that we can use to learn
the latent space and so have a
reconstruction task.
But it's also something that can be
interpreted as a generative model.
So, if your goal is to reconstruct
the input, then your input here is going
to be to the Z
that you
drew from that distribution. So, it's
going to be the latent representation of
X.
But if your goal
is
to generate just a new image
then you would actually draw that Z from
the prior distribution. So, the question
is the encoder gives you a mean and a
variance. It does not give you something
deterministic exactly. It gives you a
mean and a and a variance. And what
you're doing is just drawing from that.
So, you have
Yes, you You from that. So, great
question. So, the question is well, if
you have a generative model here, why
would you bother and just use diffusion,
use flow matching, use all these things?
It's a great question. You have a number
of differences between the two, which
makes diffusion, flow matching, and
score actually perform better than VAE.
One of the differences is here you only
go from latent to pixel in just one
step, whereas the other ones you have
several steps that just allows you to
put more compute in there. That's one
reason, but there are some others that I
hope we can get to if we if we get some
time, but we're going to see the
relationship between the two.
The great question. Yeah.
The question is does the latent space
look like a normal distribution? So,
it's
there is something that makes it
makes it be regularized quote unquote to
be a normal distribution. It depends on
a term
that you can tweak with respect to a
coefficient that we're going to see.
And depending on the value of that
coefficient, it may look more or less
than a normal distribution.
But we're going to see that.
Cool. So, the first time I saw this
model, I was confused. You may be
confused now, and I hope
what we're going to see will make you a
bit less confused.
So, here
one thing that I want to say is
in the autoencoder case,
the loss function was pretty clear.
You would just try
to
estimate
the reconstructed output in such a way
that it's as close as possible to your
input.
But here you have a bunch of
distributions everywhere.
There's not like an obvious way of
expressing that without doing some math.
So, what I propose is that we derive the
loss function for this model,
which I'm not sure if I can tell it now,
but I'm going to tell it is called the
variational autoencoder,
and we're going to see what makes it
variational.
So,
if you remember,
in a lot of cases,
the way you derive a loss function is by
doing maximum likelihood estimation.
So, what does that mean?
That means that you have some model of
parameters theta,
and what you want is to find the
parameters theta
that maximize
the probability of your model
seeing the data.
That's what MLE is,
and that's what what what we're going to
use to see how we can derive a loss
function that can help us learn theta.
So, in particular,
we what we want is to maximize the log
of P theta of X.
So, I'm going to write it down. So,
what we want is to express log P theta
of X
with respect to something that's
we can compute.
Because this we cannot really
compute something
just by looking at it.
So, let's see how we can do that. So,
I'm going to just start
with
expressing P theta of X as a function of
something.
So,
this model
can be seen as a generative model
that starts from
a latent variable that you draw
from what we call a prior distribution.
So, one idea
of expressing P theta of X,
if you remember lecture one,
we can
consider the joint probability
distribution
of P theta of
Z, a latent,
and X,
and sum across all
latents Z
that led to X.
We can do that, right?
So, what we say is that P theta of X is
equal
to this joint probability distribution
of X,
your image in pixel space, and Z, your
latent,
and you're just going to integrate
over all possible latent
representations.
So,
this quantity
is nothing else than
you
drawing from
a prior, so P of Z,
and then using your decoder
to estimate X
So, this quantity is the integral of
your prior
times
P theta of X given Z
DZ.
P of Z,
you know. Yeah, exactly. So, it's a
Gaussian. You you know.
P theta X given Z,
well, it's your model.
The model that you want to find.
The problem
is that
you need to compute this
for all possible latent Z,
and Z is still a high-dimensional
a high-dimensional vector.
So, this,
if you were to compute this quantity for
all Z,
is actually not something that you can
do.
Cuz you would have to compute
a lot of
such quantities with given Zs
in order to get a good estimate, and
it's just not something that you can do.
So, do you remember
a similar setting we had
in lecture one?
Which is the reason why we're going to
see how we can find
a convenient bounds that could be maybe
more tractable.
Because so far I have not used the fact
that we also have a way to encode the
input in order to get latents that are
more likely to be the ones that I want
to consider here.
So, what I'm going to do now
is
to find
So, what what I want to do first is to
maximize this quantity. So, I want to
find theta that maximizes this quantity.
So, we saw just now that this quantity
is not something that I can actually
compute.
So, what we're going to do is to find
a lower bounds
that could be something that you could
compute.
And what we want to do is to maximize
that lower bound in the hope that it
will also maximize this
in order to find
our parameters theta.
So, let's do it.
So, you would have the following. So,
I'm going to just come here. I would
just say that P of X is equal to the
integral of
P of Z times P theta
of X given Z, which is just at that
point. I'm going to use the same trick
that we did in lecture one, which is
to involve
>> [snorts]
>> the output of the encoder,
and here it is Q phi
of
Z given X
times Q phi of
Z given X.
So, what does this represent, this?
So, this represents
the probability distribution
of the Zs that are likely to occur for
this given X.
Because here,
in the original form,
what you were doing was to just sum
across all possible latent
representations out there.
But there are many of them.
So, it's like you know, you're in the
ocean, and
someone tells you, "Okay, just look
through the whole ocean."
But the thing is
only
a small subset of the of the Zs are
actually the ones that you want.
They're actually only
a subset of the Zs that are the ones
that are responsible for your X to
appear.
Which is the reason why we're
letting this Q phi of Z given X pop up.
And this expression, so this is equal to
this,
and this gets equal to just expectation
of P of Z times P theta
of X given Z
over
Q phi of Z
given X
where your Z
is drawn from Q phi
of Z given X.
So, why am I doing this whole thing?
Because what I want to do
is
to take the log of this whole thing.
I want to take the log of this whole
thing.
And do the same trick as we did for the
DPM, which is the Jensen's inequality.
I'm going to say that it's the
expectation
of the log
of this whole thing.
So, I'm taking the log of this quantity
which I expressed
as a function of the output given by the
encoder
for which I can find a lower bounds.
And now we're going to see that these
lower bounds
is actually something that is tractable.
We're going to see it now.
So, what I'm going to do is to just
rewrite
this expression so we have
So, the expectation of the log of the
whole thing
which is equal to the expectation
of
the log of P theta
of X
given Z
plus
the expectation of
So, I'm going to be a little bit smart.
I will say minus the expectation of
the log of
Q phi of
Z given X
over
your prior distribution.
So, here what I just did was I take the
log of P Z times P theta of X given Z
over Q phi of Z given X.
And what I did is I just
I used the property of the log, which is
logarithm of the product is the
the sum of the logarithm of the terms.
So, I had this one pop up.
And this one I just rearranged. I put
the denominator in the numerator and I
added a minus.
And given that it's an expectation for
both of the both of these
that are over Z drawn from your encoder
output, which is Q phi of Z given X.
This term
is actually
the KL divergence
of
Q phi of Z given X
and your prior.
So,
what does this all mean?
What this all means
is
in order to find the theta that
maximizes quantity
we derived a lower bounds
that is something that we'll see
structable. So, it's this expression
which we have
divided into two terms.
So, the first one is expectation of the
logarithm of P theta of X given Z.
And the other one is a KL divergence.
So, we're going to see that these two
terms are actually quite interpretable.
The first one
is actually
a reconstruction term.
Because if you remember
P theta of X given Z
is a normal distribution
with fixed variance.
So, we know the probability density
analytically.
So, if you take the log
of the probability density of a Gaussian
you actually end up with something super
simple, which is the norm of
X, so the input and
the reconstructed output.
And then this second term
is actually a term. So, back to your
question.
It is a term that penalizes
the distribution coming from your your
encoder
being far from this fixed prior
distribution.
So,
loss functions usually have a
coefficient in front of this term to
penalize more or less
the fact of being far or close
from this prior distribution.
And depending on the coefficient there
you're going to have
either something that will
look like a normal distribution or not.
So, that is the part of your last that
will allow you to do that.
I'm looking at the time. I'm not super
in advance, but I'm going to just pause
for 1 minute if you have any questions.
So, the question is we're pushing the
distribution of the encoder to be more
of the normal distribution. So,
we want to do that to normalize the
latent space, but we don't want to do
that too much.
Otherwise,
so the the prior distribution is P of Z
doesn't care what X is.
And in other words, if you push it too
much
towards something that is
just static
it will just
not
consider the input at all.
It will collapse. Yeah, so that's called
posterior collapse.
Um so, just one one other question and
then and then I'll move on. Yeah. So,
the question is So, we had this image
with the little
spikiness and that was the autoencoder,
the standard autoencoder part. This one
is actually structuring the latent space
in a way that makes it more smooth, more
well put together. And yes.
So, I'm going to speed up a little bit.
Let's go through our checklist.
Tractable dimension?
Yes.
Compact representation?
Meaningful representation?
Yes. Yes.
Oops. Truthful representation?
No.
Wait, why is that?
So, these models
they actually
end up reconstructing the image
in an imperfect way.
And what we actually obtain are more
blurry images.
And so, I'm hoping that in the next 9
minutes
we're going to see why that is the case
and how we can solve it.
So, first of all, let's look at the loss
function that we have derived, which is
composed of a reconstruction loss and a
regularization loss.
So, the reconstruction loss, what is it
What is it?
We have not derived it here, but I am
telling you that if you derive it
it is the pixel wise L2
between
the input and the reconstructed output
the reconstructed input, sorry.
And so, what that means is if the
generation
is a little bit off by a few pixels
it will actually get very penalized.
Because the distance is pixel wise.
So, what ends up happening is
the model tends to produce values that
are more averaged
which produces this blurriness
sensation that you're seeing.
But then you will tell me, "Well, Affine
the standard autoencoder also had
that loss. So, why didn't it happen
there?"
Well, the fact is it also happened
there, but it's even more pronounced
here
because
of
the structure of the model that we have
defined, which is
that the latent representation
is not a one-to-one mapping
with the input X. It is not.
Instead, what we have said is
a given input X maps to a probability
distribution, like a set of probable
points that could be actually latent
representations of this X.
So, the model will introduce this
uncertainty even more
in the reconstruction that it will
output.
And
here what we want to do
is to combat
that blurriness
sensation because here,
if we were to perform
diffusion in the latent space,
and if we were to decode
the final output in the latent space,
the last thing that we want is for our
output to be blurry.
We We do not want that.
So, now we're going to see
a couple of strategies that will allow
us to combat
that blurriness
artifact that we're seeing.
And the first one is going to see to be
about
a kind of loss that's called the
perceptual loss.
I'm going to say exactly what that
means.
So, let's imagine you have your image X.
The intuition here is we don't want the
reconstructed output to be compared with
the input
pixel to pixel because it does not allow
for, you know, little shifting here and
there.
So, what we want instead
is to be able to compare
the input and the reconstruction
more in terms of
similarity that
something that looks similar to you as a
human.
Perceptually similar.
So, how can you do that? Well,
there are some models out there
that
that are convolutional base, for
instance,
that actually extract features from
these images
in their layers.
And here,
we refer them as feature maps.
And one good things One good thing about
this feature maps is that they represent
things from this image
that have more of a spatial invariance
compared to the original image.
So, what does that mean?
That means that
if you have two images
that are slightly shifted, slightly
different,
then their feature maps
will actually not be that different.
So, the idea here is
instead of comparing
the pixel-based images one to the other,
we're going to compare
their representation, their feature maps
one to another.
I'm not sure if you've heard that loss,
but there is a loss that's called LPIPS,
so learned perceptual image patch
similarity.
So, it is a loss,
or it is a metric, I should say,
that is composed of
the difference between the feature maps
of two images,
and that are weighted by a coefficient,
which is here WL.
There are coefficients that are tuned
by the authors of this paper in order to
match what humans consider as being
perceptually similar.
So, long story short, so by the way, the
formula is scary, but it's not that big
of a deal. Like, we don't
care about the whole thing. What we care
about is that we're not comparing images
in the pixel space. We're comparing
images
between their feature maps.
And what we're saying here is that the
feature maps of two images
better reflect
their structure, their details,
and they are less sensitive to spatial
differences.
So, that is one strategy.
So, one thing to note is that we would
weight this loss by some coefficients.
You could think, "Okay, this loss is
answering all our needs. Let's have the
the weight for this part of the loss be
super high." Well, if you do that,
actually there are some bad things that
also happen.
So, we have what we call checkerboard
artifacts,
which as you can tell is like a
grid-like artifact in the image
that is similar to this one. So, you
don't want to have too big of a weight,
either.
So, that's one. And then, a second
strategy to combat blurriness is what
we're going to see now.
So,
the problem that we have is that
the decoder of the VAE is outputting an
image that is blurry.
So, one idea could be to ask another
model
to tell you whether the input image, so
in this case the blurry image,
is a real image or not.
And based on that,
what we would do
is incentivize the this other network
called the discriminator
to distinguish
outputs coming from the decoder compared
to real images,
which would then flag
blurry images as being fake.
And we would penalize
the decoder
for generating images
that would be flagged as fake by the
discriminator.
So, have you heard of GANs before?
So, we don't have time to talk about
them in detail, but I think the slide is
summing up what is happening. So, you
have two models
that are competing with one another.
The decoder that wants to produce images
that the discriminator can cannot
distinguish from being fake.
And the discriminator that wants to
distinguish the output from the decoder
compared to images from real life.
And what this will do
is incentivize the decoder to produce
more realistic images.
And in doing so, it will help with
removing that blurriness.
So, that is called adversarial loss.
So, what we saw
was that the original loss of the VAE,
which we derived here,
led
to outputs that were that were
too blurry. It was fulfilling all the
wish list that we had, but it was not
leading to a truthful reconstruction,
which is the reason why we saw
two different strategies
to add to our loss
to counterbalance the tendency for the
model to produce blurry outputs.
So, these are
the perceptual loss and the adversarial
loss.
So, before giving it to Shervin,
I could not let you without telling you
how this fits together with the
diffusion models.
So, in particular,
the reason why we did this whole thing
is for us
to use our diffusion flow matching model
not in the pixel space,
but in the latent space.
Because computationally, it's just
cheaper,
and it's able to scale.
So, now we're going to see what our
strategy for training and inference is.
So, for training, what we do is we first
train the VAE
exactly like we like we saw.
And then, what we're going to do is to
train our image generation model like
using, for instance, flow matching
in
the latent space of the VAE.
And we're going to see how we do that.
So, let's suppose we have an image from
our target data distribution.
We pass it through the encoder.
Our encoder gives us
two quantities, so the mean and the
standard deviation.
And what we do is we sample from that
distribution to get our latent
representation.
And then, what happens is in our latent
space,
so we hopefully have a smoother latent
we have our Z1, which corresponds to the
clean image.
We sample
from the noisy data distribution.
And here, I'm just illustrating the case
of flow matching. We have ZT, which is
a weighted combination of the two.
And what we do is we optimize for, let's
say, our
uh velocity like the L2 loss. We do
that.
This is for training.
So, how about inference?
Well, let's assume that you have trained
your model.
Then now, what you want to do is to
generate new images.
So, what you're going to do is to first
sample
from an easy distribution in the latent
space, so for instance, Gaussian noise.
And you're going to use
the
for instance, flow matching, the
velocity that you have learned
to solve it numerically
and arrive at let's say point Z1
which is the latent representation of
your
ends
trajectory.
And what you're going to do is to use
the VAE decoder
to decode that output back to pixel
space.
So let's see how it looks like. So this
is your latent space that you have
learned.
You sample from the noisy distribution
in the latent space.
You solve numerically the OD using the
learned vector fields that we've trained
right before.
You obtain Z1.
The problem is Z1 to us is doesn't mean
anything because it's it's not in the
pixel pixel space.
So what you do is you take that Z1.
You pass it through the decoder
and you obtain
the image in pixel space.
So to conclude
what we've seen is a way to find a
latent space that is of lower dimension
that is smoother
and that is also able to
preserve the details of your image.
And so in particular, we say that the
encoder acts as a low-pass filter.
Because what it does is
represents
those images mostly based on their
semantic similarity.
So this is actually something we have
not seen, but
for a diffusion model to find
all the details in its exploration is
much harder than finding something that
is semantically what it wants to
generate.
So this is the reason why
we're giving the decoder
the task of conveying all the low-level
details, all the perceptual
elements.
And the role of the decoder is to take
that latent representation
and to make it
an output that is full of details, that
is realistic
and that is matching what we want.
And for that reason
you have the encoder and the decoder
which you
you would think is symmetric
but in practice, the VAEs that are used
in conjunction with diffusion models are
such that the decoder
is actually bigger
than the encoder.
Does that make sense? So we have we
don't have a lot of time. So one thing
that I put down there is
a longer form version of everything I I
mentioned in some very interesting
articles which I recommend reading but
not
mandatory as part of this class which is
um some results from Flux 2 which is a
text-to-image model
and uh the LDM paper, the latent
diffusion model paper
that is at the bottom of the slide.
Yeah.
So uh the question is
what should we think of the role of the
encoder and the decoder? So at the end
of the day what you want
is to have an easy time generating
images at the end of the day.
And what you want is to not have too
high of a computational burden for your
diffusion model to operate.
So what you want is a latent space that
is
low in dimensionality and that is easy
for you to learn.
So what does easy for you to learn mean?
It means having a space
that is not super spiky but that is more
smooth.
And in particular
in order for you to obtain such a space
it is actually something that in
practice
something that you can obtain if you
focus on the semantic meaning of these
images as opposed to capturing all the
lower-level details. So in other words
what I'm saying is
even if two images are perceptually not
very similar but if they represent the
same thing
what we want for these images is to be
located not too far from one another in
the latent space.
So we want the encoder to mostly capture
the semantic meaning.
So the encoder, what we want is to make
the job of the diffusion model easy.
And so so this is the learnability you
will see in those paper the those paper
learnability.
So once you have images that are
semantically similar, that are close to
one another
you do your diffusion process. You
obtain let's say a point that you say,
"Okay, this is the latent representation
that I want to have in the pixel space."
So now the job of your decoder
is to make sure that all the details
that you want to have in this final
image are there.
So in that sense
in contrast to the encoder
the decoder's job is to make sure all
the perceptual details
are present in the final decoded image
in the pixel space.
So in that sense you have these two
different roles of the encoder and the
decoder. So you want
your diffusion model to have an easy
time learning existing
and you want a space that has
some semantic information which is what
I mentioned the encoder can do.
But what you want at the end of the day
is to have an image that contains the
details that you want.
And that part is mostly something that
the decoder can help with
in the decoding
stage.
Okay, I'm 10 minutes over time but with
that I'll give it to Shervin.
Thank you, Afshin.
So now we're going to see together how
to represent the conditions that we have
at the input of these generation models.
So the first kind of condition that we
can have is a text one.
So the text world when it comes to
representing embeddings has a long
history
and I'm not going to go through the
whole history of how we represent
embeddings. I'm just going to focus of
how people do it today. And the way they
do it is with transformer-based
architectures.
So
let's first see how we can decompose the
input sentence.
So we have this concept called
tokenization which is the practice of
decomposing
any piece of text into atomic
components. So you can have something
that operates at an arbitrary level
word level subword level or character
level.
And the subword level is usually um
algorithms that learn how to best
decompose the the tokens with respect to
the data by focusing
um vocabulary
budget on those tokens that most
frequently occur.
And
the tokenization technique that's most
used these days is subword.
But for simplicity, the one that you're
going to see in the slides is more
towards arbitrary but it's just for
representation purposes.
So
who knows about transformers?
Okay, so most of you. So there is a
sister course that talks about
transformers at length. I'm not going to
talk about transformers at length but
just give the main pieces of information
that you should know.
So
it is an encoder-decoder
architecture that is centered on the
concept of attention.
And it came out in 2017 and most of the
language models that you see today are
based off of it. Even uh vision models,
you have many of them that are based on
the transformer.
And
the good thing about it that made it
work well is that its inductive biases
are based on the concept of attention
that proved to be generalizable.
And let's focus now on this concept of
of attention.
So if we had to summarize in a single
sentence what it is
it is the practice of representing a
given piece of input
as a function of all the others.
And here with the example a cute teddy
bear is reading, if we want to represent
in the space of attention the token
teddy bear what we do is that we have
embeddings for all these tokens.
You have learnable matrices that will
turn them into the space of queries Q
keys K and values V.
And what you're going to learn is a
distribution of keys of of this key over
keys.
And the weights that you obtain are
going to be those that you place on the
corresponding values.
So in summary, you're able to represent
the embedding of teddy bear with respect
to uh the others in this sentence that
way.
And you can write this down in matrix
form
which is this soft max
term that represents this probability
distribution.
So the square root of DK is just a
normalizing constant
that prevents the sum from becoming too
large the dimension of this queries and
keys.
And multiplied by the value which is
which carries the embedding
of the of the values.
So you can find these attention layer at
the three different locations. So two of
them are
self-attention layers. So in the encoder
and another one masked self-attention
which conveys the fact that tokens can
attend
only on those that were predicted
before.
And then you have another layer where
attention occurs which is called
cross-attention which will make these
queries attend
on other encoded
keys and values.
So this is the high level.
And
in just a few words the main components
is that
your input tokens are converted into
embeddings with a learnable layer. You
add
some information regarding the position
of your tokens.
Then you make it through go through an
encoder that will apply this concept of
attention and also add on top of it
some learnable mechanism to
add some
um
like complexity
for each tokens representation which is
those feed forwards this feed forward
network.
And then at the quarter level when you
want to generate let's say a sentence
you start with some placeholder top
token
that you
for which you add position embeddings as
well
that you self-attend and then perform
cross-attention with respect to your
encoded tokens and then you also have
feed forward there
to finally obtain
your output.
So I'm telling you all that
to mention that there is there are
locations where embeddings can be
extracted out of all of this. So if you
use the encoder part of the network you
can find
the end of the encoders
a location where you have an encoded
meaning of your inputs tokens.
And this is typically one of those
locations where
you could say these are the embeddings
of my inputs.
Okay, great. So
now doing the same for images let's say
you have a condition that is based on
images.
One thing that is pretty nice is that
everything that we mentioned just now
can be reproduced with images.
So all these token representation
are just numbers
and you could well
represent
these numbers
you can associate them with patches of
images and this is what
the VIT vision transformer paper does
which follows the same principle
but instead of learning embeddings on
tokens you learn embeddings of on
patches of images.
So everything says stays the same
and you can perform
tasks such as
um
image classification with it.
And something that I haven't done in the
text space that we can do here together
in this image world is to see how these
pieces come together
in in this example of a teddy bear
reading a book.
So here you decompose your image into
these patches that we mentioned.
Each of these patches you have a
learnable layer that gives you an
initial representation of what they
mean.
So in the case of text you would have a
dictionary of tokens that are mapped to
embeddings but here you have something
that is more continuous.
So you can have a linear layer you can
have a convolutional layer you can have
everything you want.
So you have
something at that stage
that gives a representation of these
patches
and then in
classification setting you have a token.
So for example here CLS
that will carry information regarding
the class
of your image that you want to predict.
So each of these can be represent
represented by embeddings.
And we mentioned that we have position
information encoded in them.
And next class
we're going to see more about
position encoding and and all of this.
So
I'm not going to expand too much.
So you have a representation for each of
these patches of your input
that you then feed your VIT
and exactly as we mentioned
at the output of the encoder
you can locate one specific embedding
that carries the semantic information of
your input image. So here it would be
the output corresponding to the CLS
token.
That here you project to learn a
classification task for example. But
let's say you are at a
representation stage
of your of your workflow you would just
take the embedding that you see in
orange at the top as your representation
of the image.
Okay, great.
So
something that I didn't tell you is that
for text
doing that process is cheap in data
because the task that we use to learn
these models
is self-supervised by nature. We anchor
on next token prediction in the world of
text and you have a bunch of text in the
internet it's easy to have such data.
And
and it's easy to to learn.
But in the image world if you want to
handcraft a similar task that is as
meaningful as what we have in the text
world
we have a a bit more trouble.
One of these candidates that I just
shown is the classification task.
For example for which you need to gather
labels.
So it's it's quite expensive.
And I just want to say that
one
follow-up work
that works on embedding of images that
we're not going to see in details today
is
DINO self-distillation with no labels
for which the concept is to have a
teacher and a student model
that
receive this different kinds of inputs
and they aim at learning similar
probability distribution in the output
that are prototypes. So
I think it's a very interesting paper to
see how we can build representations out
of no labels just out of the images
themselves.
So
Okay, great. So now
we went through how we can represent
text and images So
did everything make sense so far? So we
went slightly fast but I just want to
make sure we got the gist
out of it.
Yep. The comment is in the image world
do these
images become tokenized? So you can
think of them that way. The only
difference is that we don't have a
dictionary of tokens but rather we look
at them in a continuous manner because
in the text world you would just have a
lookup but here learnable so that's
exactly right.
Yep.
So the comment is depending on how you
cut your image you can have errors.
Yeah, totally right and this is why it's
a hyper parameter. This VIT model comes
with different patch sizes and this is
one of the trade-offs. Yep, I mean
absolutely.
Okay, awesome. So now that we have seen
how to represent text and images
separately you might wonder Okay, hey I
want to generate a new image with
conditioning that depends on both let's
say. Or I want to condition on either
but I don't want to have to deal with
two spaces.
So how would you bring them
together?
So
what we want
is to learn a relationship between text
and image
that has
this nice property of when you look at
the embedding space
you want similar
concepts
either image text to be grouped together
and dissimilar ones to be pushed away
from each other
with respect to some metric.
So let's take the example of our teddy
bear and something totally unrelated
let's say a water polo ball.
So
the teddy bear with the text token teddy
bear is similar.
Same with the water polo ball image and
the water polo ball token.
But
the opposite pairs are not. And we want
a way to quantify each situation and
learn it automatically.
So how can we do that?
So let's like build a matrix of these
two. So this is just phrasing in a
different way what I've just said.
And what we want is Teddy bear and the
image of Teddy bear to be of high
similarity.
So
what we're going to do
is project these embeddings that we
talked about in the same space.
So we're going to build these vectors
with the representations that we just
saw before.
So what we're doing here is the same. So
we have our patches of images alongside
the CLS token that you pass through the
VIT architecture.
And then
once you get the last
embedding representation, what we're
going to do is to project it in a space
that we're going to have it shared with
the text space. So the property of that
projection layer that we built
is that it's going to output a vector of
same dimension by construction as the
one for text. So we do that here.
And then we do the same
for the text world.
So by the way, I mentioned to you
that we would look at embeddings at the
end of the encoder layer. And here I'm
going to I'm showing another procedure
to get embeddings of text, which is to
pass
all of these tokens to the decoder
and decode
the one corresponding to the last token.
And by construction of the attention
mechanism and the transformer, this
embedding coming out of the last token
is going to represent the whole
sentence. So it's another equivalent way
of showing the representation of tokens.
And we're going to take that
representation and project it
as we said in that same shared space.
And by construction, these U and V are
now comparable. You can do dot products.
You can compute similarities.
And we define this similarity S
variable that is the scaled dot product.
And
one thing that we can do now
is to transform this notion of
similarity into some score
that can be seen as a probability
distribution through the softmax
operator.
So if you compute the exponential of the
similarity between image Teddy bear and
token Teddy bear over
the sum of the exponentials of this
image Teddy bear and all the other text
tokens
you find the probability distribution
that this image corresponds to that
piece of text.
So okay, you can do that from a fixed
image to the set of texts.
And you can do that
on the other hand
with a fixed
piece of text token to all the images.
So you can have both ways.
And what we do
is that we can define two losses that
look symmetric
that represents respectively how similar
like the penalization of any error of a
fixed image based on all pieces of text
and similarity error of a piece of text
with respect to all the images.
So it's symmetric cross entropy. And
then when we sum these two losses, we
can obtain a final formulation
that represents what we care about,
right?
So that is the key of the CLIP model
that trains the representations of both
image and text worlds into
like
with this way of training things. So
what we do is that
we scrape a bunch of images and captions
off of the internet. And then for a
given batch, we say that a given image
has its associated caption as the true
label. And then all the other captions
in that batch are negatives. So it's
called in-batch negatives.
And you do the same thing
of
captions with respect to all the images.
And you obtain that way um
final embeddings in the text and image
encoders here
that we generate the representation that
you're looking for.
Okay, so
here just to give some order of
magnitude, the paper talked about 400M
pairs
of data.
And it's great. You you you reach great
accuracy even on supervised tasks.
But the issue here is this softmax. So
every time you have a huge batch of
data, you need to build a similarity
matrix of
a fixed image with respect to all the
captions and symmetrically. And this is
not
great computationally.
And also from a meaning standpoint, what
you're truly saying in your loss is that
you want to maximize the similarity of
your true image caption pair, but you
don't truly
enforce the fact that all the other
similarities should be each very small.
So some follow-up work
reframes this problem into sigmoid loss
one. So instead of saying
I want this
one image to be to have a probability
distribution that matches that of the
true caption, we take one caption and
one image separately and we ask
ourselves the question, do they match or
not?
And by doing so you don't have all these
similarity matrix complexities. And also
you have a stronger statement at at your
loss level
that's like pushes the positives
together and the negatives further
apart.
Okay, so
So any questions on this contrastive
learning part?
Yep. The question is, do you start from
a pre-trained encoder and what weights
do you change? So I think in the paper,
they start from scratch and they train
both encoders from scratch. You could
very well
freeze or like start with some
pre-trained encoder,
freeze all the layers, let let the last
layer. I think typically you would just
train everything.
Yep. And in real life
I think you just wouldn't train
anything. You would just pick something
out of hugging face. But yeah, in
practice, since it's easy to get all
this data. So typically you would scrape
the internet,
look at images and look at alt tags in
HTML. So you can get all these pairs. So
I think you're in such a setup where
doing it from scratch makes sense, but
what you suggested makes sense as well.
Yep.
So I think it depends on what works
best.
Yep. So the question is, is the
transformer architecture a prerequisite
for this task? Not at all. So you can do
it with any encoders.
And the reason why I talked about
transformers is to ground the way of
encoding into what people do in
practice. But you don't have to have
this architecture as a prerequisite.
Yep.
Okay, awesome. So now we're going to
reach the most exciting part of the
class, which is finally, how do you
guide our generation model with the
condition?
And
we're going to go back to thinking about
what we discussed these past lectures.
So we had these diffusion mechanism
where you are at this given step here XT
+ 1 and you want to find the less noisy
version of the image XT.
And
the thing that we want to do now is to
do that with a condition that I called
Y, but that you might see called C in
papers.
So you want to guide the generation
towards generating a sample that follows
Y.
So a first idea that you might have is
okay, it's a classification
there is a concept of classification. I
can come up with a classifier of weights
phi
and try to make it work. So how could
you make it work?
You start from this probability
distribution that you want to sample
from.
And then by applying Bayes' rule,
like the conditional version with the
right
arguments for A, B, and C,
you obtain this product
of two probability distributions
that you can see on the left represents
the
one-step generation process that we
know.
And on the right side, you have
the probability distribution of Y given
XT, which would typically be what the
classifier would give you.
So now let's see how we could sample
from this.
So taking a look at the
probability distribution on the left, so
if we recall the first lecture, let's
say in the DDPM world,
you know that this probability
distribution follows a normal
distribution of a mean that we learn
and of variance that is following a
noise schedule. So we don't
learn it. It's something that but that
we have.
So we know the expression of this.
If you look at the probability
distribution of
of this,
it's
something that we know.
So we have that on one hand and on the
other,
we look at our probability distribution
at the end of the classifier.
So here,
why are we not happy with that? I mean,
we have the data of the probability
distribution, you just have to put
the noisy image to your classifier and
then you you have it. You have a
probability distribution. Why are we not
happy with that?
It's because we cannot
plug it into that product equation that
we saw and then easily sample from it.
We want to reframe it in a way that we
can have this nice
Gaussian distribution that we had for
example at the unconditioned generation
step.
So what we do is that we
have a trick that expands this
probability distribution with a Taylor
expansion and then you come up with
like a first term that is a function of
XT.
And
when you plug
the
probability, I mean, the log of P phi
that we just found into this product,
you see that the probability
distribution that you want to learn is
simply the same one that you had but
with a shifted mean.
Yeah, so I I just want to take a pause
for a second. So we went through a
process that
where we tried to find an easy
probability distribution to sample from.
So we went through through a series of
equation but all I want you to know from
all of that is that we tried to
get to this state
where we can
sample from an easy distribution and
that's what we reached. So in some way
we're we're happy.
And then here, what's good about it is
that you don't need to retrain your
unconditioned model. So your mu theta
and your sigma t are things that you
know.
And
there is a downside to it. Now I
mentioned classifiers, you need to learn
a classifier that operates on noisy
images.
And and the process here is that you you
need to have that classifier that
predicts
some probability distribution and then
you need to take the backward pass
on the network in order to find the
gradient.
Did that make sense so far?
Okay, great. So when we sample from the
distribution that I mentioned in
practice, one thing that people see
is that it doesn't produce samples that
follow the Y condition enough. So this
is why you see that W factor being
introduced that can be tuned
to force the generation process to
follow the classifier's gradients more.
And
this is what we call the guidance part.
So we saw that we don't have to retrain
the unconditioned model in order to
sample from this distribution but on the
other hand, you need to have a
classifier that operates on top of a
domain
that can be composed of noisy images.
And the bad thing about it is that you
typically don't have that out of the
box. So
it's typically something that you have
to train as part of your training
process
which is a downside.
And also
the fact that you need to compute the
backwards pass of your classifier is
quite expensive which is also not great.
And something else that I would mention
is that
you not only need to have that extra
classifier and spend all these budgets
to compute the gradients but you need to
make sure
that the
like that the signal of your gradients
scales
well with the the coefficient W that you
introduce. So you need some
hyperparameter tuning to make sure that
the operation that you're doing
is meaningful.
So one question that you might ask
yourself,
is it possible to do this guided
generation without the needs of a
classifier?
And the answer is yes.
So if you use Bayes' formula,
you can see
that you can define an implicit
classifier so called PI of Y given XT
based on the
generation, like the unconditioned
generation of your image
and the conditioned generation of your
image so conditioned on Y.
Which means
that if you have a network that can
generate an image without any conditions
and that can generate an image with a
given condition, then you can solve this
problem by plugging this equation back
into what we had, which is what we do
here. So the equation that I
that I showed regarding the like the
distribution of the next sampling step
can be written in epsilon space. So I
mentioned this uh
Gaussian distribution of shifted mean,
you can rewrite the noise that you want
to predict
into one that
takes into account that classifier
signal.
And what the authors of the paper
of the classifier-free guidance paper
did
is that they plugged in the
P phi expression with the implicit
classifier the expression that I just
mentioned before.
And they obtained this very nice
expression
that is a function of the noise that we
want to remove
based on a model that isn't fed any
condition
and one
for which a condition is provided.
And what you can see is that there is
this W term in the middle that is that
has about the same interpretation as the
one that we saw before
that will tweak
the generation
to be more or less towards the condition
that you bring.
So there is that and then now we're
happy because we no longer have to train
a separate classifier phi, we can just
rely on the uh generation
uh network's weights theta.
So how does that look like in practice?
So with a certain probability called the
unconditional probability,
what you can do is sample an image from
your training set
and a time step and noise
and try to predict the noise from it. So
which is what we saw in the past.
And with probability
1 minus P unconditional, what you can do
is do the same
but then you use the embeddings that we
saw in the parts just before
to feed that network with this
additional information and predict the
quantity of noise to remove
with the condition Y.
So you do that 1 minus P unconditional
times.
And
what you get
is something interesting uh which is if
you look at
how your
predictions look like. So let's say the
noise that you want to remove is the
point top left and then the noise that
you want to remove when you have a
condition is the one in the middle.
Then the guidance hyperparameter W
will push
the prediction of the noise more towards
the noise of the conditioned sample.
And the reason why we do that is that
because in practice,
if you don't have this hyperparameter,
you tend and if you just use the
conditioned sample noise
as the one that you used to denoise your
noisy latent,
you might obtain images that do not
follow
your prompts very closely. And this is
why we have such a hyperparameter in the
first place.
Uh in terms of numbers, the guidance
parameter is typically set to like it
just a few. I think three.
In the paper, let's say typically more
than one.
And I just want to put a disclaimer here
that the the equations that I showed
with the
with the classifier guidance
hyperparameter
might have several definitions. So you
might see formulas formulas with W in
there, W plus one. So all these values
of W that you take are dependent on the
equation that you operate from.
So this is one. And then the other thing
is that in practice at training time the
proportion of time for which you show
unconditioned
generation is typically 10 20% of time.
And
this time you do not need to have
an additional classifier at hand and to
do an expensive backward pass.
But
you still need to do two inference steps
because we saw that
the equation has this epsilon theta of
XT and no condition and the one with the
condition which is two forward passes.
So you still have some extra cost
although it's better
than the other technique.
And this technique
CFG is the one that's most used today.
Okay.
So any questions?
Okay, great. With that, I hope you have
a great weekend.